right now let's take to sri lanka where
there's a developing situation police
have been using tear gas on protesters
at the prime minister's residence what
on earth is going on
uh let's take you to colombo nicole is
standing by nicole tell us
more of people have been streaming
towards the prime minister's office this
is one of the buildings that they
haven't occupied the reason they're
heading down the road there is because
they want the prime minister reynold
wickrakesinga to resign along with the
president now the president gotta buy a
rajapaksa is set to resign as we know
he's already left the country he's in
the maldives he went out on a military
jet and it's expected that later on
he'll from the maldives head off to
another country so it's
a real d-day here in sri lanka
essentially it feels like this is the
end of the rajapaksas this is what these
people have been demanding for for
months they've been on the streets
they've been enduring hardship the
country's economy has collapsed they're
fed up with it but clearly the the
potential of today's resignation that
we're expecting of the president isn't
enough for them they want him and all of
his cronies out of the country
uh so that prime minister's office is a
bit further down there they've told us
that they're not going to storm it but t
gas was fired earlier today
as they got closer to it
whatever happens though sri lanka is
still in a dire economic situation the
economy has collapsed as you drive
around the capital colombo it's cues
after cues of people lining up for
petrol for gas for food for medicine and
that's because people say the rajapaksa
family has wasted the country's money
that they've overspent
that they have also made terrible
economic decisions
and they really want to see them out
people are having a hard time
even surviving on a day-to-day basis one
in five people are hungry here right now
and
today we're going to wait and see
whether people
end up celebrating the end of the
rajapaksas whether they eventually
decide to move out of the buildings that
they have occupied in colombo
or whether they continue their protest
on the streets